this is the photograph that put Prince
Andrew in the spotlight and sent ghilane
Maxwell into hiding it was taken in
March 2001 the Duke of York has his arm
around a 17 year old girl
Virginia gue Frey she says she was
forced to have sex with him by the
woman's smiling in the background
ghilane Maxwell both denied the
allegations against them for someone so
well-connected Maxwell has been very
elusive in recent months in years past
she was a high-rolling socialite friends
with the rich famous and powerful
Maxwell was a regularly photographed
fixture on the Manhattan party circuit
but always enigmatic often seen rarely
heard d'Alene was introduced by her
father to the richest and most powerful
men in the world whether it was in
Washington or in London or in Paris
Berlin or Moscow she would see what
power and wealth could buy he didn't
miss anything she had a yacht she had a
plane she flew on Concorde she had
unlimited amounts of money ghilane
Maxwell was the ninth and reportedly
favorite child of Robert Maxwell the
disgraced British media mogul who died
in mysterious circumstances in 1991 his
body was found floating near the yacht
he named after her I'm proud of him and
I love him and I miss him
and to be angry pointless he's dead
following her father's death ghilane
Maxwell went to the United States the
family's reputation ruined and their
wealth depleted in New York she
reinvented herself starting a career in
real estate and was often snapped mixing
with another property tycoon one Donald
J Trump
but it's her friendship wid Prince
Andrew that attracted interest and
raised questions they knew each other
well Maxwell and Eckstein were guests on
a shooting weekend at Sandringham in
December 2000 d'Alene Maxwell was an
Oxford graduate an heir s to a tarnished
fortune but never seemingly a victim of
her infamous surname she managed to
shake off her father's past but her own
has now caught up with her
Alistair bungled skynews